بعد الجلسه الشهيره في الكونجرس للرئيس
التنفيذي لتيك توك امام لجنه مجلس النواب
للطاقه والتجاره اعتبر العديد من مستخدمي
تيك توك ان اعضاء الكونجرس لا يعرفون كيف
تعمل التكنولوجيا ومنفصلون عن العصر
الحديث
الاسئله التي وجهت الى تيوب كانت عنيفه
وجعلت الرئيس الشاب عاجزا عن الاجابه في
كثير من الاحيان لا لعدم امتلاكه الاجوبه
الشافيه ولكن للصعوبه فهم الكثير من
النقاط التي طرحت كما حصل هنا لنسمع سؤال
ان
هل باستطاع التيك توك الدخول على شبكه
الواي فاي الخاصه بمنزلي
عذرا لم افهم السؤال
التيك توك الدخول على شبكه الواي فاي
الخاصه بمنزلي
اما اجابه احد المستخدمين فكانت هذا سخيف
اسئله ممثل الامه الامريكيه اثارت موجه
كبيره من السخريه لدى الشباب على مواقع
التواصل الاجتماعي وخاصه مستخدمي تيك توك
الذين اعتبروا انها دليل على استهداف
التطبيق الشهري بعينه تيك توك لا يختلف
ابدا عن منصات وسائل التواصل الاجتماعي
الاخرى مثل فيسبوك وتويتر وانستجرام وفي
الحقيقه فان مشروع تكساس الذي يطرح الان
من قبل تيك توك مهم للغايه ولكن المخاوف
من امكانيه اختراق الحكومه الصينيه
للحسابات الامريكيه قائمه دائما جمع
الحزبين الرئيسيين في جبهه واحده تماما
كما فعل بلاديمير بوتين ولكن في المقابل
نظم بعض النواب من مناهضي حظر التطبيق
وقفه احتجاجيه مخالفه تماما لما رايناه
داخل الجلسه وهذا النائب الامريكي شمال
بومن يقول
التعديل الاول يقفل لنا حريه التعبير
وبحضر تيك توك نحن نخالف هذا الحق ونحن
نمنع منصه جمعتنا وساعدتنا على النمو
باعمالنا الى مستوى اخر ان حظر تيك توك
سخيف
وامام هذا الكم الهائل من التعليقات على
الجلسه الشهيره اعتبرت صحيفه نيويورك
تايمز ان بايت نقلت الى واشنطن اكثر من 30
مؤثرا على المنصه للدفاع عن التطبيق بعد
جلسه الاستماع
العربيه واشنطن